Hello Dr. Good good afternoon. Good
afternoon. How can we help you?
I have
the testosterone problem. I get
too much facial hair and also have
carpal tunnel.
What do I need to take for these?
Okay, I got carpal tunnel. What what was
the first one you had?
Facial a lot of facial hair. The doctor
said
my body make a lot of too much
testosterone.
Okay. And how much do you weigh?
About 250
25 lbs. 225, okay. And do you have any
other issues, any diabetes or high blood
pressure or arthritis?
I got joint pains.
My ankles swell sometimes. I have um
varicose veins.
But I haven't been diagnosed with any
blood pressure. My blood pressure is
always 110 over 70, but there's diabetes
in my family.
Okay, well it's not genetic. Okay,
Charmaine are you there?
Yes, I'm here. Okay, before we go to
Charmaine, Helen, how tall are you?
I'm 5'10.
Okay, 5'10.
Okay, so 5'10 for a woman I'd like to
see her weigh 165, 170. So you need to
lose about 55, 60 lbs here. And she has
carpal tunnel, she's got joint pain,
varicose veins, has a lot of facial
hair. What would you what would you do
dietarily for Helen, Charmaine as well
as a supplement program?
Well, for those issues, I would get her
on I would get her on two healthy brain
and heart packs, but I'd also add the
gluco gel, the M the MSM,
the vitamin D3,
and I'd also have her get the Z-Firm.
Z-Firm, yeah I'd go a little wild there.
I'd give her the Z-Firm two bottles a
month. You can take three of those twice
a day. What what others
would you give her?
Besides all that? Mhm.
Um Let's see from Good Herbs. What would
you give her from Good Herbs?
Uh
Female Hormone Support. Okay, Female
Hormone Support. Yeah, I'm not
Yeah, get yourself two of those dropper
bottles and take a full dose twice a
day. The Char's exactly right. One two
healthy brain and heart packs a month,
full dose everything. It breaks in
dinner time. Vitamin D3, three of those
twice a day.
The um gluco gel, 15 of those a day.
That's two large bottles a month, five
five and five. MSM, I'd go with three of
those twice a day. That's one large
bottle a month of the MSM.
And they're all designed to support and
promote maintenance and repair of
cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissue, disc between
vertebrae, bone matrix, bone itself.
And what would you do for the weight
loss? She needs to lose about 60 lbs.
Oh, Rev, of course. Rev, yep. And take a
dropper full under your tongue. Um 30
minutes for each meal. One bottle will
last you a month at that.
And um taking the two healthy brain and
heart packs, the cofactors necessary to
tone up the elastic fibers in your veins
are in there. And so these are designed
to support healthy elastic fibers in
your skin, your veins, your arteries
all over the body. And so you're going
to see some benefit there. Your body
wants to heal itself, but it needs
aromatics to pull that off.